csu chef markus söder hat sich auch zu
diesen bildern geäußert und er ist auch
auf bundesverteidigungsministerium
christine lambrecht los gedanken
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
einen schönen guten tag die bilder sind
furchtbar erschütternd wie wir aus der
ukraine gesehen haben das ist ein echter
zivil bruch und das bestätigt die
schlimmsten befürchtungen die viele seit
wochen haben die bilder erinnern an
srebrenica und dann kriegsverbrechen die
eindeutig sind diese kriegsverbrechen
müssen geahndet werden es ist es
notwendig alle notwendigen rechtlichen
schritte zu unternehmen um in den haag
dieses kriegsverbrechen verfahren
einzuleiten es kann nicht sein dass ein
bürokratischen hürden diese wichtige
lebenswichtige hilfe am scheitern kann
entweder durch die bundeswehr oder auch
die möglichkeiten die die deutsche
industrie an der stelle liefern kann
muss so schnell wie möglich durch den
bund erlaubt werden es braucht noch in
dieser woche eine liste an vorschlag und
auch eine lieferung
erkennbarer weise ist das zuständige
bundesverteidigungsministerium und auch
die ministerin selber komplett
überfordert und führt auch dazu dass der
ruft in deutschland in der nato genießt
deutlich geschwächt würde wohl die
bundesregierung versucht ja mit viel
geld beim thema bundeswehr wieder die
vorderhand zu kommen dies ist eine
blamage wie deutschland hier in dem
thema präsentiert wird und kann noch
nicht so weitergehen markus söder
spricht von einer blamage bildpolitik
chef jan schäfer ist zu uns ins studio
gekommen was sagst du dazu ist das so
recht ist so oder so hart müsse
christine lambrecht oder ist das völlig
zu recht also man hat ja nur dass die
bundesverteidigungsministerium
eigentlich von anfang an diesen krieg
diese krise wenn man das mal salopp
sagen darf überhaupt nicht im griff
hatte von keinem zeitpunkt an man hat
eigentlich eindruck sie ist immer noch
in dieser arbeit uns einarbeitungsphase
immer noch in den modus ich bin frisch
ministerin geworden und muss noch lernen
das ist auf der einen seite auch
eigentlich ganz normal denn wir wissen
ja dass diese hier geflohen diese
krise dieser krieg wirklich extrem
schnell über die bundesregierung
gekommen ist das ist richtig auf der
anderen seite hat man nicht ein und das
frau lamprecht jetzt im richtigen kriegs
modus ist das sehen wir bei der ganzen
frage
waffenlieferungen beispielsweise das ist
eine peinlichkeit an die nächste die
sich dort breit und bei der wir immer
wieder feststellen alles mögliche bleibt
auf ihrem schreibtisch liegen aber wird
nicht entschieden es wird geprüft es
wird nachgejagt man muss da immer ganz
vorsichtig sein heißt es aber nun ist
doch gerade die zeit für hands-on das
jetzt was getan werden muss ist sie
tatsächlich falsch besetzt wir wissen
immer wieder und hören immer wieder dass
ich gerade schon sagt ja auch wünsche
nicht nur von der ukraine direkt sondern
auch von anderen von anderen ländern die
über die ukraine kommen an die
bundesregierung immer wieder auf ihrem
schreibtisch liegen bleiben dort wird
also nicht richtig schnell gehandelt die
frage ist steckt möglicherweise auch
olaf scholz dahinter bremst also auch
das kanzleramt aber natürlich muss man
jetzt sagen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt ist
frau lamprecht mit dem posten den sie
macht erkennbar überfordert und deswegen
ist das was markus söder jetzt gesagt
hat sicherlich eine berechtigte
forderung die die opposition stellt wir
hören schon des längeren das auch in der
spd darüber gemutmaßt wird welchen
posten könnte man denn frau lamprecht
möglicherweise anbieten sie fremdelt
erkennbar mit der bundeswehr aber jetzt
geht es erstmal um die frage natürlich
olaf scholz was könnte er stattdessen
bieten das ist gar nicht so einfach aber
wie geht es jetzt weiter also ich meine
sie verspricht ja immer mehr waffen zu
liefern kommt dass jetzt auch schneller
in gang also die bundesregierung
geliefert auch waffen über die sie gar
nicht offiziell spricht was immer nur
bekannt wird ist vor allem dass immer
wieder nachfragen nach waffen auch
liegen bleiben wir haben sie auch bei
den strehler raketen gesehen haben
anfang hieß es ja es kann gar nichts
geben dann gab es 500 streller raketen
das hieß ja dass das potenzial dann
eigentlich erschöpft und dann wurden
noch mal ich glaube etwas über 1500
raketen zusätzlich geliefert also es
geht dann ja wenn der druck nur hoch
genug ist aber man hat bei frau
lamprecht eigentlich immer den eindruck
sie reagiert sie kommt nicht in die
vorhand sie ist nicht die führende kraft
und wir müssen uns als deutsche leider
immer wieder von europäischen partnern
anhören dass wir das bremser land sind
und wir sollten eigentlich ehrlich
gesagt auch gerade mit blick auf unsere
geschichte da kann sein dass die ukraine
federführend unterstützt widerspricht
mehr wenn du es anders sie ist aber es
gibt nun auch mutmaßungen die sagen gut
wir liefern das ganze nicht weil wir gar
nicht können weil eigentlich unsere
bundeswehr auch so desolat ist unsere
panzer unsere maschinengewehre das
funktioniert alles gar nicht dass es eh
schon eingerostet das können wir gar
nicht rüber schicken glaubst du dass es
auch mit ein grund ist es ja so dass zum
glück nicht nur die bundeswehr oder wir
waffen von der bundeswehr nehmen müssen
deutschland ist ja als viertgrößte
volkswirtschaft der welt auch einer der
größten waffenhersteller beziehungsweise
in diesem land gibt es sehr große waffen
hersteller und deutschland ein großer
großer waffenexporteur das heißt hier
werden viele waffen hergestellt und was
wir hören ist ja sehr interessant
während es bei frau lamprecht zum teil
wochen dauert bis es die freigabe gibt
waffen zu liefern geht es offenbar bei
wirtschaftsminister robert habeck viel
viel schneller denn dort müssen ja
waffen exportiert werden dann auch
genehmigt werden das funktioniert viel
schneller und da sieht man hier und
lässt du dir das na ja das ist er hat
sicherlich auch mit bürokratischen
vorläufen etwas zu tun das ist ganz klar
und die waffen die dann hergestellt
werden aus der industrie da gibt es
möglicherweise ganz andere prozesse das
läuft schneller als bei der bundeswehr
aber am ende glaube ich ist es nicht
falsch wenn man sagt da gibt es einen
willen und zwar bei robert habeck die
ukraine zu unterstützen wir erinnern uns
vor knapp einem jahr hat robert habeck
ja auch gesagt man müsste defensivwaffen
an die ukraine liefern das war noch im
wahlkampf usa massiv gescholten worden
ich glaube zu unrecht und wenn man das
heute anschaut dann hatte er recht also
er hatte immer schon den drang zumindest
in den letzten neun bis zehn monaten die
ukraine zu unterstützen mit waffen das
kann man bisher kontrollamt recht nicht
unbedingt sagen lass uns noch mal kurz
auf butscher gucken diese schrecklichen
bilder die ja auch dich erreicht haben
olaf scholz hat gestern weitere
sanktionen angekündigt er jetzt warten
wir den ganzen tag darauf dass was
passiert was könnte denn eine weitere
sanktion sein es gibt auf jeden fall zur
zeit um einen großen abstimmungsprozess
mit zwischen den europäischen partnern
ganz klar ist dass deutschland hier
nicht alleine voran schreiben kann
annalena baerbock und robert habeck
haben ja gestern auch gesagt dass es
noch weitere sanktionen geben muss und
die große frage ist ja steht am ende
dann
eine sanktion die die bundesbürger und
auch die wirtschaft durchaus hart
treffen würde nehme ich dann wirklich
ein öl- und gas-embargo etwas anderes
wird uns noch gar nicht mehr übrig
bleiben eigentlich weil alle anderen
sanktionen müssten wir doch zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt eigentlich ausgeschöpft haben
wenn wir das nicht hätten wäre das ja
nun auch in skandal es riecht es gibt
noch ein paar banken die beispielsweise
auch weiter in dem sogenannten
swift-abkommen dabei sind also von
sanktionen bisher nicht so belegt sind
aber wenn man jetzt mal wirklich den
wird man zu sagen darf den großen
sanktions hammer rausholen möchte und
das muss man glaube ich nach den bildern
die wir da auch gesehen haben ausputzer
dann wird über kurz oder lang das thema
öl und gas embargo und zwar dann
endgültig auf der tagesordnung stehen
fragt sich natürlich warum hat man den
hammer noch nicht rausgeholt tag 40 des
krieges das ist eine berechtigte frage
die kann man durchaus stellen die
wirklich auch diskutiert gibt ja auch
politiker wie norbert röttgen
beispielsweise von der cdu der schon
seit wochen sagt lasst uns das gas und
das öl oder die den import aus russland
sofort stoppen das ist möglich weil wir
mit mindestens 200 millionen euro
täglich putins krieg indirekt an auch
finanzieren mehr oder weniger direkt
indirekt und der sagt das schon länger
und ich habe auch den eindruck dass in
der bundesregierung mittlerweile
diesbezüglich ein umdenken stattgefunden
hat es geht stärker richtung öl- und
gas-embargo andere länder schaffen sie
auch dankeschön jan schäfer dankeschön